manuel santos
eu fiquei passando o fim antes de tudo
para baixo você aguentar mas tanto tempo
eu vou falar um pouco é da vela portanto
e demi próprio das minhas experiências
com a vela
meu nome é antônio anos e ela sempre foi
pra mim ela e omar sempre foram para mim
um dos meus de um dos meus sonhos uma
das minhas paixões
eu comecei a jogar aqui nas 16 do sul e
portanto este era o meu grande oceano
foi aqui onde eu aprendi a entender o
vento a perceber o que eram os elementos
da natureza as correntes é perceber um
cadastro a natureza com o qual é a
reação que nós tínhamos com a natureza
ainda mais quando quer orientar e coloco
no virar do processo dentro da bahia no
ano de imaginária mente então sei sempre
quando é que a bordo
ok que é o meu lado segurança meu porto
seguro tanto mais tarde conheci um
senhor que era amigo meu pai e que tem
um bar na favela e portanto foi logo uma
paixão à primeira vista passou a ser
logo meu grande ídolo porque tinha um
bar que eu passei efetivamente navegar
num bar com a série não é uma praxe
doença serve como eu tinha e no umbará
êxito porque nem importante passar
efetivamente teve um parque uma
tripulação para senhoras com ele
arranjar fixaria e ir parar o barco até
porque estamos a falar dos anos 80 não é
e nós nessa altura tínhamos muito pouco
comprar portanto evitávamos muito e
criavam de junho
é nessa fase também aprendi uma coisa
nova pra mim foi nova que foi a
tripulação tanto bateu era um barco que
tinha tripulação e aquilo para mim foi
uma grande dúvida foi uma grande coisa
ruim no momento não estava habituado a
estar com o convento com as águas com
barco
tinha que gerir uma tripulação ok e
muitas vezes perguntava porque
precisamos de uma tripulação quer dizer
eu estou habituado há nada que havel e e
adoro estar aqui com o mar e com essas
coisas todas e não precisamos uma
tripulação tem feito sempre muito
sozinho
é eu sou engenheiro de profissão
ok o meu cargo hoje tenho como missão é
transformar angola num dos anos de
telecomunicações em áfrica e nesta minha
nesta minha função na função que o
desempenho tenha efetivamente recebido
muito bem quais são olha o tipo de
negócio aí como é que nós conseguiremos
chegar aos nossos objetivos como é que
nós podemos transformar efetivamente
este processo em realidade
contudo uma das coisas que também
percebi rapidamente depois de ter
efetivamente esta tarefa e esta
embarcação dinâmica na mão é que eu
realmente preciso de uma tripulação não
consigo ver este barco a bom porto
de uma forma solitária posso dizer-vos
dividir aqui uma experiência que eu tive
nos anos 80
nós ficávamos das festas e os nossos
ambientes até um ditado por recolher
obrigatório nos podia nos permitirá sair
então uma vez nós temos várias vezes das
festas e dos ambientes e iremos andar à
vela
saímos às três da manhã temos no bar que
passávamos o dia todo mundo então uma
vez aconteceu que estávamos todos lá já
não é claro que a maior dor mir uns com
um eu cai água e no momento em que a
água é conseguir uma guerra agora
colocar e os meus colegas pulsavam todos
em pânico a gritar o que fazemos agora
como é que podemos roubar como é que
eles faziam então aí percebi pela
primeira vez que anos que tenham estado
comigo no mar tantas vezes nenhum deles
efetivamente perceber como é que se
maneja roubaram então eu perceber que
mesmo numa situação em que nós dominamos
todos os processos e nós pensamos muitas
vezes que as pessoas que os rodeiam
também não sabem fazer
nós realmente precisamos sempre do hiv
ou seja nunca conseguimos fazer tudo
sozinhos
ok é eu uso muito a minha experiência do
jogador nas meninas estavam todas as
minhas equipas profissionais
tive que convencer os meus amigos
deixaram de jogar a bola para virem
fazer ela comigo tive que muitas vezes
preparados foram néis e tal possa
convencer a ficar 11 dias inteiros na
vela quando não era uma coisa que acho
que estava então é que o que eu quero
fazer agora é um caminho uma analogia
ele o que a vela e o que é competição de
vela com a gestão empresarial corpos
disse
precisamos de uma tripulação nós
precisamos não é de uma qualquer
tripulação nós precisamos de uma equipa
boa e precisamos quem é justo as velas
quem vejo o rumo quem precisa é como é
que vão estar as condições climatéricas
lá mais à frente é essencial e muito
importante porque quer do indivíduo
perceba quais é que são as suas tarefas
e que tem uma autoconfiança muito grande
naquilo que faz
o emprego uma equipe engajada é é
composta uma equipe vale é uma é como se
fosse um engenheiro cair que é composta
por vários elementos que são
complementares aos antigos saber
trabalhar em equipe é fundamental para
podermos estar sincronizados e
alcançarmos as metas e os objetivos que
efetivamente se pretende isto tanto no
mar como uma equipa numa equipe
precisasse empresarial
a energia gerada pelo trabalho em equipe
é o elemento capaz de transformar os
sonhos e realidade os desejos em matéria
concreta uma equipa treinada no ativada
e conhecedor da sua responsabilidade é
capaz de levar bem alto grau de
desempenho e atingir regularmente os
seus objetivos
os líderes têm por isso um papel
fundamental ao nível da gestão
empresarial e mesmo numa gestão é de uma
embarcação à vela
são aquelas pessoas que são capazes de
transformar e de convencer as pessoas a
segui-los roque e são capazes de
conseguir fazer isso saiu sem força nem
o processo ou seja as pessoas que seguem
segue não voltaria mesmo porque
reconhece nele efetivamente uma
capacidade de liderança deste processo
vou dar um exemplo por exemplo os
capitães das duas embarcações dos
piratas porque era um indivíduo que era
um excelente pela tripulação e esta
tripulação muitas vezes era uma
tripulação de bandidos de criminosos
mas essas pessoas têm que ser de tal
maneira carismáticas quero efetivamente
capaz de atrair a atenção dessas pessoas
que circulavam na altura como homens
livres de fazerem aqui efetivamente o
que quisessem mas eles eram capazes de
atrair efetivamente a sua atenção para
que os seguissem nas suas missões e
daquilo que eu já vou fazer hoje em dia
nas redes sociais os seguidores são
aquelas que se associam alguma coisa que
efetivamente está em 3 soc e associam se
dessa forma uma forma voluntária e por
isso os seguidores são normalmente muito
apaixonados pelo aquilo que eu sei o
conhecimento ea antecipação da
informação é fundamental o conhecimento
dos ventos é do filme por exemplo que
tipo de velas é que nós vamos usar para
que o banco possa continuar a andar com
com a velocidade que se pretende e não
podemos velocidade quando temos que
mudar e sabemos que o tempo vai mudar e
no entanto não não colocamos a nossa
tripulação é enrico no mundo empresarial
a antecipação daquilo que vai entender e
as mudanças no mercado são fundamentais
essas mudanças fazem já digo fazem
efetivamente uma empresa está numa
posição vantajosa ou não não podemos
perder o foco tem que estar sempre
focados todas as decisões a serem
tomadas têm de ter em conta as
consequências dos seus atos
a escolha é permanente e decisões têm
que ser tomadas em tempo útil
é nós esperamos muito tempo por uma
decisão é o facto de esperamos pressa de
decisão pode ter consequências graves
graves nos resultados finais que nós
queremos alcançar
mas foi uma decisão errada do que
nenhuma decisão
contudo a decisão consiste num contexto
de atuarmos em frente ao alcance dos
próprios objetivos porque nós temos que
estar focados nos resultados têm que
estar permanentemente focados nos
resultados por isso temos que cumprir
com como pensar rapidamente os erros que
cometemos
isto isto é não é problemático errado
ok errar faz parte do processo de
aprendizagem quanto mais erramos mais
rapidamente nós percebemos que não é que
é o caminho que temos que tomar choque
então errar é um processo de evolução é
um processo criativo o que nós temos que
foi efetivamente fazer é não
sistematizar os nossos erros
a perfeição é o acumulado de
experiências entre uma comparação
daquilo que é certo e do que aquilo que
é errado
ok temos que errar para saber qual é o
caminho o caminho certo
temos de conhecer muito bem as nossas
empresas de mesmo as nossas embarcações
nós conhecemos os nossos equipamentos
nós conhecemos os nossos processo
nós temos a capacidade de saber quais
são os nossos limites e se nós soubermos
quais é que são os nossos limites nós
podemos mitigar o risco que colocamos
tanto as nossas embarcações quando as
nossas empresas do ponto de vista da
atividade que estamos a desenvolver
temos que estar sempre na vela por
exemplo está sendo constantemente a ver
qual é resultante entre o efeito do
vento e o andamento do barco
isto porque se o andamento do barco não
for adequado nós temos que estar
constantemente ajustar as velas
exatamente para dizer desenvolver este
processo de andamento o mais rapidamente
possível nas empresas é muito similar
nós temos estar sistematicamente a
desenvolver o status quo do processo de
forma a podermos evoluir treinar e
capacitar as nossas equipas
são ações cruciais do ponto de vista da
gestão cada um tem que saber o que fazer
no tempo certo de fazer uma orquestra
toque desafinada é horrível sorrir não é
uma uma empresa que esteja desorganizada
não consegue esperar a nível do mercado
quanto mais cedo iniciarmos a
aprendizagem das nossas equipas mais
erros elas vão conter naturalmente mas
mais sucessos elas vão viver e portanto
terão um andamento muito mais positivo e
ter uma performance muito melhor quando
efetivamente tiver em desempenhar o seu
o seu desempenho eo principal de tanto
passar nos o passado é naturalmente uma
das grandes fontes de informação daquilo
que nós precisamos portanto nada é como
passar vamos punir mas já navegadas
forma podermos efetivamente criada
escola há um ditado no marco que há um
ditado muito conhecido que diz quem vai
tomar a via sem terra
certo ou seja nossas empresas devem
planear estar preparadas para diferentes
controversas do mercado temos de ter
reservas para momentos de aperto e temos
de ter planos de contingência para os
momentos controversos no mar
existe sempre um plano b isto é nós
quando vamos provar que estamos no meio
do oceano
estamos sozinhos e quando estamos
sozinhos temos sempre aquela garrafa
d'água que está guardada pra alguma
ocasião aquilo que o fone satélite que
está fechado sabe que ninguém usa ou
seja existe sempre um plano b
então é preciso efetivamente nós
estávamos preparados do ponto de vista
empresarial para as mudanças
ok as crises são mudanças bruscas de
percurso e o que efetivamente acontece
nos momentos de crise é que nós somos
colocados em situações controversas de
alto risco e situações numa situação
normal nós não nos colocaríamos então a
crise danos efetivamente a oportunidade
de nós olharmos para as coisas de uma
forma distinta
eu vou te dar um exemplo se nós tivermos
numa regata e apanhámos uma tempo estava
no meio do mar
nós não conseguimos fugir dela então o
que ela vai nos permitir é que nós temos
que nos adaptar a essa tempo instável e
que pelo simples fato de estarmos em
plena tem estado
temos a grande probabilidade chegarmos à
frente dos outros porque nós
sobrevivemos até o estado
nós então temos a capacidade de chegar à
frente dos outros isto é esta crise que
é efetivamente uma coisa temos esta
possibilidade de apoiar o desporto
sucesso de outra dimensão
ou seja nós temos que sair não falha do
conforto muito obrigado